the youtubers it's Charlie, this is going to be my korra finale video
lot's of debate about the ending and the
series in general
so let's do the thing.                                  I know that we all really want to talk about
is the ending I do feel like Mike and
Brian just absolutely dropped the mic
and as backed away if you were to press
them at a future Comicon
I think that they would stay pretty
ambiguous about the ending
it's really common thing for writers
especially television now when there's
an ending that's really polarizing
to disk and leave it to the fans to
decide one way or the other how things
went down
so just remember that when you're
arguing cannon with other people on
tumbler
because this is the finale I'm giving
away two copies of the book 3d be the
all you have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video
so careful for spoilers from the finale
if you haven't seen the episode yet
starting with top 10 moments number ten
hammer at the train station
wanna make the request me episode I
raise me lo I can handle anything
other looks like row hand at the end the
episode is gonna be way crazier than me
lo
other he seems little more benign the
songs you seen later was called hungry
little lemurs
there so many songs an avatar at some
point I'll try to do a video for my
favorite avatar songs
especially from the original series as a
president haven't released an album
usually at comic-con sometimes those
things like this thing secret tunnel at
comic-con 2014 it was pretty fun
number nine Prince we with the Badger
malls I'll under the given the top
moment
it would be avatar that bad your moles
in the song he sang was actually a nice
spin on secret tunnel
I'm surprised at how smart we got in the
last couple episodes
and it was nice to given that big win
other technically it was a badger more
when
never let the truth get in the way of a
good story asbury says
for those that didn't remember from the
original avatar series it's the rhythm
other song but the bad Hermosa
responding to
that telling her to take out the cards
number eight Miller has a plan to take
out the giant mech
really disable it with the Airbender
paintball guns isn't it crazy that there
was like a windshield wiper system
installed in the giant mech that x is
surprised me more than the paintballs
I guess could be resisted expected to
run into a lot of inclement weather
and I just love me lo smashing is based
on the last two
now be like a really good dashboard a
really good like phone lock screen
I said it before but I feel like he is
the reincarnation obeying even though
technically Korea is
is because she's the Avatar me lo
inherited being sense of humor
but I don't think the aim was quite as
good as an artist number seventeen cora
verses the giant mech
round one they were able to take it down
but there was actually a really awesome
team effort with the air benders
cora and bowling on the ground lobby
bending the deal is really crazy is how
good
a metal bender cougar is but they kinda
explain it later
but why she's able to bend the J making
everyone else isn't outside is coated
with platinum so that they can benefit
the outside but the can bend it from the
inside
that so when SouFun in Lynn got inside
later they were able to rip that shit
out a bit
interns rockabilly though could be read
is one of the best metal benders in the
world
next to top that is top still the best
there were a number of attacks against
the Mac I do feel like they did a good
job
escalating things so this actually came
pretty early in the first episode so
it was a big deal but the later fights
to get much more epic
number six I'm afraid there are no more
things to do sir
Julian fairground one so many things
happen this scene for stuff he did the
JP like I thought he would
a course that didn't work is because the
power source inside the giant mech was
self-contained
not only was the power source isolated
it was speared by energy so it was a
little bit different from a traditional
electric circuit
the way he tries to explain his
backstory is just so much fun
I had an ostrich horse name missus beaks
it is that line
before the circus people came in took me
away doesn't make you feel
like he was part obsidian circus troupe
I don't think that he was but does the
many he said circus troupe all I could
think about was Seans picture firmer
circus days
eric is like a homer simpson type
character where they can with crack
between personality traits
ago from really smart to really done
back to release smart
in the span of like two minutes I don't
know then was counting but I just
thought it was hilarious but the sheer
number of times
they let different characters in the
episode use that phrase do the thing
number five is on his father wants to
turn the hummingbird makes
into mosquitoes and then gives his life
as predicted he did help out
I like the way this in a mock they did
given that found among with Asami
like she said at the end of the episode
i'm glad that I family for gave him
before it was too late both floors tile
balance but I think you could also
subtitle it forgiveness
but the big part a balance is forgiving
people you take that as many commentary
from Mike and Brian
and but please forgive us that there's
not going to be another avatar series
the animation when they were flying
around the neck was actually call to
is it is very King Kong moment with the
neck trying to swat them like actual
flies
number fourteen court inside the Mac so
this is really like a Death Star moment
where they all get inside
start ripping it up they're really three
different plot lines you have korber SES
coupe era
up at the top with the liquid metal
fight then you have boleyn ma ko
in the engine room trying to destroy
this beard finds any have limits to you
in trying to take out the weapon
first does one appreciate all the
cross-sections just like the internal
mechanics it just looks so awesome
you could definitely tell they went all
out with the animation on this episode
disparate contrast they could have
totally taken the easy route never shown
the inside the Mac
it would have been so much easier for
them to animate and so much cheaper
so actually going inside the death star
way above and beyond the call of duty
never mind how badass all the fights
were so let's start with the core fight
upper top
I love that the balls inside those
maneuvering mechanisms like the things
that could be reused to maneuver the Mac
where liquid metal think I've those is
like the gears that the way that she
ships the Mac around
other does kinda seem like she's bending
from the inside the neck like she's
bending the internal structure itself
it's also nice reference to the poison
from the end the book 3
you can kinda tell the core is on our
game like the minute she jumps up there
cool your throws that her she bend right
back at her at no point does the middle
cover her face like never gets on your
skin
so she is definitely a much better metal
bender at this point and it's not always
evident because she hasn't spent a lotta
time fighting
in book four like before wasn't so much
about fighting accorded have a lotta
a big bending when she wasn't in the
Avatar State
moving down a little bit bulletin Marco
Michael italy had his here a moment
I did kinda think he was gonna die and
was getting up in the spirit world
and they were gonna see a man like
oppose credit seen like they would seem
at the end of the episode with I wrote
trying to have tea
but to be fair you really only make it
into the spirit world is a spirit
if your spiritual I'm is highly tuned I
rose one of the most spiritual people
from the original avatar series so
that's that's why his spirit survives
in the spirit world youjizz
automatically go there so to be fair
if michael had died he actually would
not have ended up there unit has died
so they would've been a huge bummer so I
am glad that bill and saved him
whenever he had that not too I did
think the Bowlin was gonna like smack in
the face and then escape with them
and bowling was gonna do something and I
want to be complaints in book three was
why he didn't like the bed mean what
sooner
but he did get her in the end I was
definitely surprised that the explosion
in the giant mech
like it was more of a cross-section that
it was like a nuclear blast
expected it to be this big spear call
explosion
like whenever the spear portal was
created like a giant believed was
expanding from the inside
and how cool was bowl into lava saw now
that I've come back to his aunt lottie
saw
so then moving to them a little bit you
have CNN papon
totally awesome sister team up you
really do notice their heroes of all
ages
in the Avatar universe but you have been
alleged women you have children yet
really young children like me lo
I think that's one thing that they try
to add from the original avatar series
mostly action focused on the young team
avatar but the core universe is little
more diverse
enters a age is represented don't in the
surprise me was
how easily could be rude able to take
them out I get that she's a better
better than them
but it seems like she just able to swat
them like flies but she bent them to the
metal arm then rips it off
there are always little things like that
that bug me when they don't quantify
people strength I think a lot of it just
has to do with communicating them off
guard
if you ever wonder why two years always
able to beat the crap out of people
it's usually because you catch them by
surprise even a good fighter can go down
if they're not prepared just like or
getting our ass handed to are at the
beginning a book for
number three cores fight with the giant
speared by a weapon tears open
a newspaper portal so how about the
reveal a Coro step into the spirit fines
in the face that Jenkin and
that was probably my paper reaction shot
from the episode dislike
00 shared this is like a beer is as the
Legos crazy moment
it wasn't quite the same thing but yeah
she definitely when look crazy
by their specific points that you can
point to a longer path for you they okay
she has this really good plan
she's acting very rationally but her on
the back in that can in like 10 who Vera
on this Jan Canon is the craziest thing
in the world
she has absolutely no scientific
understanding of how scared by an energy
works
if you are giving in a tight bond is
someone on the street and saying
okay you know go play with this out that
there was any other way that it could
have gone down
like something terrible had happened
this paper really was the biggest
surprise the episode
anything could happen
line to local jumped up the speared by
its courage is totally taken them all
out
had this been like it HBO series I think
there would have been a lot more blood
his beard binds would have been ripping
people up
but this is Nickelodeon it's a
children's show I did expected some
point
the Coro would take a full blast from
the gun makes you eat it
neither die or absorb it somehow so was
glad that they took it to that level.
agia crazier than that cords explanation
was totally satisfactory
just that sheer spiritual energy tore a
hole between the physical world
in the spirit world creating new spare
portal it how beautiful was the spirit
world
on the other side that portal the other
side to the southern portal
is like this big desolate area next to
where that World Tree is
like that they chose to make this area
look all flowery a nice like a nice
meadow
very calming and serene number to Julian
Barratt sweating
so couple wasn't being this episode
between Julian Barratt we learn their
full names
Julie moon answer picnic blackstone
Barrick
and he didn't recognize it immediately
they were getting married on Air Temple
Island
pretty much like olive downtown was
completely destroyed overtaken with the
Bidens bear portal
so if you're looking at it the actually
the animated all the characters they
could
into that scene if he ever saw The
Simpsons Movie it's just like that but
they did a big church scene where they
had hundreds of characters in the shot
normally what happens is when did you
big crowd shots is the only put faces
on the first couple arose and then all
the background people that are in focus
these two lesser virgins up just to save
time and energy
but in this scene be completely animate
everything is in frame
it's not something you think about right
away but because this Herculean task to
animate all these faces especially at
this number characters
in frame also nice to know shot turns
out he's in a band
we also get 20 hand and everyone kept
asking where is ro hand
look at how big is gone actually
confused him with me low when I first
saw him
a lot of the characters also got really
cool costume changes but I think that
live in chorus costumes for prime a
favorite
all the characters to get different
costumes the wedding dress Julie's
wedding dresses very nice to
alone in his party scene is also setting
up but the action is going to be for the
characters
after this episode like in in the
mythical fanfiction territory or the
comics
saw a dress that after you're done with
my top 10 list in
my number one moment the very imp
USB be not so ambiguous course I me
ending is going to be the most stupid
thing in the fandom for the rest the
time
and I'm so happy they did this way now
because I'm just like hard core course
on me
but just because the reaction that it
causes and people
just so fun to watch it all play out I'm
a big people watcher
like I really enjoy people going crazy
over stuff I mentioned it a little bit
earlier in the video but
if you were to go up to Mike and Brian a
convention in say will you please
you know say definitively yes course on
me no course on me
are they just really good friends or is
there something going on here
they prolly would not answer you now
because they're trying to be mean
but just because they think that it's
more fun to leave it to the fans to
decide
to be fair I think it is in the subtext
here but
if you to get at the literal
interpretation know they're just really
good friends
because the children show on Nickelodeon
the regular time to address
same-sex relationships that's really let
the subtext in children's programming
but you could argue that sponge bob is a
gay character but there's no way in hell
they're ever gonna say
yes but drivers gave no he's not gay
that's why I'm really proud that my can
Breitbart so happy to go to that place
isn't into the big not to the benefit
the little fan service but it's also a
really smart wat
to say hey you know baby there is
something going on here
in yes I do think that there are a lot
of same-sex relationships in the core
universe in the Avatar universe
the best example I can think up is
double door JK Rowling
said after the fact that double door was
a gay character even though they never
directly addressed it
inside the series or inside the books
just to be fair to all parties to the
mic or parties in the course on a
party's
most the argument is the on tumbler our
Twitter about whether or not this is
canon
is just the measure up how good you are
as a argue or are debater
so just because someone is able to
convince someone else
one where the other doesn't necessarily
make a Canon I would actually be a
little upset at Mike and Brian came out
in said definitively one way or the
other as I think it's too much fun
to debate is a more minutes to this is a
nice mere for the ending
where paying c'est ca Tara let me know
that what was your favorite moment from
the finale
and what you think about the ending like
which way do you fall on the spectrum
so just addressed the next logical step
for some the characters
we pretty much explain his turning to
Earth Kingdom into a democracy
the gonna be independent states to
operate just like Republic cities will
be more like a president
be much more democratic Marco is not
going to go with him I was actually
surprised by that
he'll just follow core round as she
tries to help the Earth Kingdom in the
rest the world
another law to complaints that he
started out as a really important
character and book 1
and slowly got less and less important
but I don't think it's so much about
that
i think is more about his own journey in
learn to be less selfish
that's why he's able to be with car
without being jealous although I do
think yet he still loves corey
still totally in love with her and just
because they're not together now doesn't
mean they won't end up together
remembered these characters are still in
their early twenties thing about the
number of sexual partners the average
person has
even if cora in Assam you're going on
out doesn't mean that they're going to
be together for the rest of their lives
fifty percent of marriages end in
divorce moving to bowl and he's prolly
gonna be following Marco around
although I'm hoping that he breaks every
once awhile to make a mover with ferric
see in healing her family their probes
going to go back and rebuild south to
kubera going to jail I'll be interested
to see how many times corbis it's her
prolly more often than she does it say
here tens and is going to continue
shepherding the air nation
interesting thing to note Harmonic
Convergence I think was responsible for
the creation about the new air benders
you could argue the tearing open the
newspaper portal increase the level of
spiritual energy in the physical world
even more so there could be even more
vendors now and they do you explain that
Republic city is going to expand
which exit think is interesting which is
the opposite of what could be wrong
wanted
it is Reiko didn't want to rebuild
around the spare parts that's why
they're expanding
overall I give the absurd Saudi plus I
mean is just amazing
they did a good job wrapping everything
up I know every like little detail was
answered
like fans are pointing to that leg break
did say we will tie up all the
storylines
but people like what happened to X
character and why character
a lot of that stuff like the little
things the leap for the comics
especially the original avatar
characters
all the big chorus story lines were tied
up and that's really what we need to
remember
this is a series about the core
characters not the original avatar
character so do forgive them for not
stopping every original avatar character
and every available seen
they did an amazing job %uh leaving the
characters in a place that lets you know
that their is a future for everyone
the minute the opposite end it all I
could see was ever
on just posting please let there be a
legend a core comic please let there be
a comic
yes I do think they will do it at some
point but it mine announcer for a long
time
right now their priority is the original
avatar comic they do seem happy to
support that
Nickelodeon had no idea what their plans
are in terms the digital content
but they are done in terms are doing
full episodes they have announced the
next project but I will stay too I am
gonna follow their career like I will do
whatever the next project is
other videos Ford let's talk about the
animation you to see how much
energy was going into all the scenes
everything which is absolutely beautiful
like each moment each scene each frame
which is this
amazing background matte painting appeal
it is totally makes up for the clip show
in really the clip show had nothing to
do with them that was on Nickelodeon
cutting their budget
really I can't say enough good things
about the series I'm just completely
satisfied with the way things ended
so I know everyone's wondering what's
going to be happening next so yes I am
planning on doing a live Q&A on my
Twitter channel tomorrow
are trying to that around 12 p.m.
pacific time so there's a link for that
in the description and yes I will be
doing
avatar videos for the original series
I'll try to post the first one
in the next coupla days but I manage a
couple more cora videos first
please leave request for doing other
animated series thank you everyone for
coming on this score journey with me is
been so much fun doing business series
also is that no it is not over even
though there are new episodes doesn't
mean that we have to stop doing poorest
up
on YouTube if you watching this on your
mobile phone on a tablet there's new
mobile Inc sapir that you click on it
the same things over here
but could hear for the CUNY opposite
tomorrow I must go into the light to
Nantwich saw
oppose summer that to the YouTube
channel and then click here for all my
other avatar videos
thank you so much for watching but all
high five please don't cry too much
it's okay to cry little bit